well that's the situation uh at the
avastar steel plant and in the last hour
we've seen our prime minister and the
swedish prime minister standing side by
side talking about a bilateral agreement
to help each other and also the
possibility of sweden joining nato and
we are joined now by adam thompson
former permanent representative of the
united kingdom's nato who's now the
director of the european leadership
network um what do you make of of this
announcement between the two countries
about this agreement
well there's a certain inevitability and
a great deal of logic
to it the
uh uk's
response in part to russia's seizure of
crimea in 2014 was to create something
called the
joint expeditionary force a
combination of the uk leading and eight
other nations
joining to conduct expeditionary
military operations of those eight the
only two that were not part of nato were
sweden and finland so what the prime
minister is doing today is building on a
multi-year collaboration uh with the
swedes and uh later with the finns
and
reflecting the very close defense
relationship that the united kingdom has
with both sweden and finland against the
backdrop of course of uh russia's
invasion of ukraine and the
consideration by both uh helsinki and
stockholm of possible membership of nato
and the key thing there is the question
of
what happens if russia
were to attack either finland or sweden
in the period between an application to
nato and the ratification by nato's 30
members of the swedish and finnish
membership i imagine that the prime
minister is doing quite a lot more today
in both capitals than
just signing uh security declarations uh
they're probably talking about very
practical military collaboration counter
cyber
the role of the joint expeditionary
force possibly a british presence uh or
that of other nato countries uh on
exercise in the two countries uh in this
gap period and and do you think that
sweden and finland's application to join
nato if indeed they do put it in would
be favorably received and it would go
through quickly
i think it almost certainly will it's
very clear that nato's 30 governments
have already taken that decision
otherwise nato's secretary general jens
stoltenberg would not have been saying
quite a number of weeks ago that swedish
and finnish applications
would be welcome
the
the only area of doubt is whether
those countries that have to have a
parliamentary ratification procedure for
allowing sweden and finland to join the
north atlantic treaty
will encounter difficulty but with the
u.s senate clearly very solidly behind
the case for swedish and finnish
membership i think that most uh nato
countries will line up and ratify and
pretty quickly and we could see sweden
and finland uh in nato as soon as this
autumn
if that happens how much of an impact
you think this will have on president
putin what do you think he will regard
uh the success or otherwise of ukraine
and the invasion of it if this is one of
the impacts
well i think part of the
purpose behind
nato support for swedish and finnish
membership and certainly london's
support for it
is precisely to demonstrate
strategic failure for president putin
over his invasion in ukraine
the ostensible reason was to stop
ukraine sliding into
the western orbit and specifically uh
hosting
nato
military capability and what's happened
he's got nato military capability uh
almost doubling on his existing borders
and he's going to be seeing if finland
joins another 830 miles of border with
nato that is clearly strategic failure
uh but it's not the only uh objective
here uh
that there are important things to be
done in terms of both reassuring and
defending
partners that are military partners for
the uk and for many nato allies they are
also
eu
partners as well
whether this is going to stabilize
things on the european continent is
another question uh russia's military
capability against uh finland or sweden
is dramatically reduced at the moment
because of
its aggression against ukraine but in
the long term it will be another source
of friction
okay adam thompson now director of the
european leadership network thank you
very much